et avec nous pour ce club Nicolas
Prisset bonjour Nicolas merci d'être
avec nous éditorialiste politique à la
tribune dimanche et Pierre jacquem
bonjour Pierre bonjour ari rédacteur en
chef de Politi on est ensemble comme
tous les mercredis on va revenir
aujourd'hui sur le discours de politique
générale de gabrielal qui a détaillé sa
méthode et son C des smicardiser la
France faire en sorte que le travail
paye c'était le cœur de son discours
vous nous direz ce que vous en avez
pensé et gabrielal est revenu sur la
colère des agriculteurs ça fait
l'actualité dans nos
régions
et pour en parler on va à tour on
retrouve Michel Texier bonjour Michel
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef à tvtour Michel on va
revenir évidemment avec vous sur cette
mobilisation des agriculteur et dans
votre région la mobilisation change de
visage
ouais la mobilisation a commencé
doucement sur notre territoire du Val de
Loire avec une première opération
escargot à a Blois la semaine dernière
des rassemblements dans les centr-villes
de tour notamment puis en fin de semaine
dernière des opérations barrage filtrant
aux barrièr de péage de laad en Touren
rien à voir en tout cas avec ce que l'on
a pu voir dans certaines campagnes ou
villes notamment du sud de la France pas
d'excès de violence une colère plutôt
canalisée puis on s'est on est monté
d'un cran avec des radars routiers
neutralisés en loircher des blocages ici
et là sur des axes stratégiques des
hypermarchés bloqués aussi c'était à
tour et à Amboise en parallèle d'un
grand rassemblement de près d'une
centaine de tracteurs à tour avec 200
agriculteurs ça c'était hier un
mouvement qui était à l'origine initié
par la FDSEA et les Jia il a été rejoint
par la Coordination rurale mais on note
des opérations en dehors de tout m
d'ordre syndical euh c'était le cas des
blocages d'hypermarché que j'évoqué tout
à l'heure ou de routes euh par bloqué
par de petits groupes de manifestants
signe d'une colère très ancrée qui
demande à s'exprimer qui s'exprime elle
s'est d'ailleurs exprimé hier soir avec
le déversement de remorques de fumier
devant les grilles de la alors alors
entre ces deux phases il y a eu un chez
nous un moment un peu particulier c'est
la venue dimanche dernier du Premier
ministre Gabriel hatal sur les terres de
l'un des députés d'André Loir dont il
est proche Fabien colbock il assuré le
service aprèsvente en fait des premières
mesures qu'il avait annoncé juste avant
après avoir tenté d'éviter cette
rencontre il a finalement rencontré
échangé avec les représentants des de la
FDSEA et des JA les échanges étaient
courtois cordiaux parfois ferme avec ses
représentants syndicaux mais sur le
terrain depuis lundi en fait les
agriculteurs nous le disent il faut
aller plus loin cette visite ne doit pas
être un moyen de les endormir pour
qu'ils retournent désormais dans leur
ferme ce qu'ils ne font pas visiblement
merci Michel merci beaucoup pour ces
précisions et ce qui se passe du côté de
de ces mouvements des agriculteurs dans
votre région merci Michael Texier et et
à très vite Nicolas hier évidemment
Gabriel Atal il était attendu sur ce
sujet puisque son discours de politique
générale tomba en pleine mobilisation
agricole est-ce est-ce qu'il est un peu
déçu sur cette question oui il a un peu
déçu parce que les annonces ne sont pas
très concrètes à part évidemment le le
versement anticip des des aides de la
PAC qui là donnera de la trésorerie aux
agriculteurs mais c'est des aides
auxquells ils ont droit il y a pas
d'argent supplémentaire c'est une
facilité évidemment pour eux mais le
grand débat sur les normes pour
l'instant Gabriel Atal s'est contenté de
d'intention
euh il est pas rentré dans les détails
il a dit qu'il ferait plus et plus vite
que ce qui l' a déjà fait jusqu'ici
reste à savoir dans quel domaine on peut
souligner que que ce sujet est
extrêmement complexe parce que les
normes elles ont Jama aucune norme n'a
été faite par hasard ell répondent tout
à à des critères à des objectifs
notamment des objectifs de sécurité donc
se pencher dans dans sur les normes ça
veut dire B rentrer dans un Maqui qui
est extrêmement complexe et et comme il
l'a dit lui-même ça peut pas se résoudre
en quelques semaines ou quelques jours
donc peut-être que c'est déceptif à la
fin peut-être aussi que les agriculteurs
euh dans leur mouvement doivent
comprendre que ils obtiendront pas
satisfaction du jour au lendemain et que
pour traiter ce type de sujet euh raller
certes c'est utile parce que ça montre
qu'il y a un problème mais ça le résout
pas ouais c'est compliqué d'apporter des
réponses rapides sur un sujet aussi
complexe pierre d'abord pour je voulais
rebondir à la question que vous venez de
poser parce que on dit de de Gabriel tal
que c'est un très bon communiquant mais
là forcé de constater qu'il y a quand
même eu un gros malentendu avec les
agriculteur parce que il avait été
annoncé que dès hier de nouvelles
annonces seraient formulées et ça a été
annoncé par la porte-parole du
gouvernement et Marc feno lui-même le
ministre de l'Agriculture qui avait lui
dit que ça irait très vite euh dans les
dans le 2è volet des annonces qui avait
été formulé est-ce que c'est compliqué
de faire des propositions oui sans doute
parce que le problème de l'agriculture
et là vous pouvez faire tous les titres
de la presse euh française tout le monde
va vous dire que euh la Colère vient de
loin et c'est vrai la Colère vient de
très loin parce qu'on a un système
agricole qui marche sur la tête hein
c'est un peu le le symbole et le slogan
de de cette mobilisation c'est des
énormes exploitations qui touchent
énormément d'argent et qui assez
confortablement finalement des aides de
l'Union européenne et puis la transition
écologique qui fait que beaucoup de
nouveaux et de de nouvelles
exploitations cherchent à faire du bio
cherche à faire du calis cherche à faire
du du raisonnable en terme de de
d'impact environnemental et eux sont pas
aidés et vivent très difficilement de
leur de leur de leurs exploitations donc
c'est c'est c'est tout le système
agricole qu'il faut repenser parce
que a priori l'Europe a mis quand même
la la transition énergétique quand même
au cœur de de de ces politiques mais il
faut que ça puisse s'adapter à l'échelle
des exploitations et c'est ça qui est le
plus compliqué et donc euh c'est quand
même je je pense que tous les Français
qui voient la mobilisation en cours sont
en train de découvrir qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens vivent avec à peine 500
€os alors qu'il passent nuit et jour
parfois dans leurs exploitations à faire
vivre leur bétail à faire vivre leurs
enfin le je pense au marchers et cetera
donc on découvre quand même une
profession qui en plus de en plus du
malaise qu'on connaitt puisquon sait
très bien que il y a c'est une
profession qui subit le plus le le taux
de suicide En France euh donc non les
annonces sont pas faciles
mais c'est très déceptif mais c'est
justement il y a un rendez-vous qui est
qui a été manqué par le gouvernement il
va falloir qu'il se rattrape mais c'est
vrai que je pense qu'il avait pas
anticipé que possiblement la
mobilisation durerait aussi longtemps et
peut-être durer beaucoup plus qu'il ne
l'imagine encore et parmi les les
questions et et les les sujets qui
concernent les agriculteurs il y a la
question des traités de libre échange et
ce matin Bruno Le Maire promet un bras
de fer pour que l'accord entre l'Union
européenne et le Mercosur actuel ne soit
pas signé est-ce que la difficulté aussi
c'est que beaucoup se jouent à Bruxelles
alors c'est pas forcément une difficulté
Orian c'est plutôt une chance que les
choses se jouent à Bruxelles parce que
le marché agricole c'est un marché
européen ça peut être aussi un marché de
proximité évidemment ça dépend pour quel
produit mais il est heureux et
souhaitable que les les le le domaine
soit organisé en concertation avec nos
voisins donc c'est plutôt une chance que
ça se passe à Bruxelles s'agissant des
des traités internationaux de de de
commerce Emmanuel Macron avait indiqué
lors de son précédent le premier
quinquena que le le les accords qui ne
respectaient pas l'accord de Paris ne
pouvaent pas s'appliquer et de fait
c'est bien le cas donc il y a une forme
de communication de la part du ministre
de l'économie de dire que voilà on va
aller au bras de fer mais le bras de fer
il a déjà eu lieu où il était déjà en
cours donc ça rappelle aux agriculteurs
que la France ne fait pas non plus
n'importe quoi s'agissant de de du du du
commerce alimentaire ça a toujours été
un sujet extrêmement sensible ça a posé
des problèmes par le passé et
aujourd'hui il y a une posture politique
qui est plutôt saine et puis qui est
plutôt respectable don c'est une
critique facile de dire que la France
serait ouverte à à des produits qu'on
aurait pas envie de manger allez au cœur
du discours hier de Gabriel Attal la
question du travail la volonté que le
travail paye et 3 m mot desmicardisé
déverrouillé débureauatisé Cécile
Sixou favori la France qui travaille
voilà la priorité de Gabriel avec une
première annonce celle de relever les
bas salaires de dmicardiser la France et
le nouveau Premier ministre veut aller
vite oui j'assume de le dire il faut
dmicardiser la France d le prochain
projet de loi de
finan en nous appuyant sur les
propositions de parlementaires de
partenaires sociaux et sur un certain
nombre de travaux d'expert qui sont
actuellement conduit nous commencerons à
réformer ce systèmere
annonceab déverrouillé l'accès au
travail et compte généraliser à partir
du 1er janvier 2025 les 15 heures
d'activité obligatoire pour les
bénéficiaire du RSA il propose également
d'expérimenter dans les administrations
la semaine de travail en 4 jours enfin
il contre ouvrir le dossier du droit au
travail avec un mot d'ordre le
débureaucratiser le libérer des
contraintes trop lourdes selon lui je
veux aussi déburaucratiser la France je
veux alléger le fardeau des règles et
des normes aussi nous engagerons après
l'été une nouvelle étape de la réforme
du droit du travail avec un objectif
clair libérer nos TPE et nos PME
simplifier considérablement leur
quotidien et leur permettre de négocier
certaines règles directement entreprise
par entreprise dernière surprise de
taille le Premier ministre veut
supprimer l'allocation de solidarité
spécifique cette allocation versée
lorsque les droits au chômage sont
épuisés valid des trimestres de retraite
sans travailler
TR inactivité d'un côté en rendant les
on l'a vu hier on l'a entendu de la part
de Gabriel Attal une volonté de
favoriser les Français qui travaillent
désmicardiser la France est-ce que c'est
le bon message pour vous
pierre ça ça pourrait être le bon
message si derrière il y avait il y
avait une proposition concrète
d'augmentation générale des salaires
mais il y a pas eu de proposition
parce que Gabriel Atal d'ailleurs c'est
assez étonnant en fait je sais pas ce
que vous avez pensé de ce discours mais
il commence son discours en disant j'ai
34 ans et puis il nous fait un retour en
arrière en 4e République c'est-à-dire
que a quelque chose de de très libéral
et très conservateur sur le sur sur bien
des sujets et puis c'est euh c'est c'est
ce que fait ce gouvernement depuis
qu'Emmanuel Macron est arrivé au pouvoir
c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est c'est tout
contre les pauvres c'est-à-dire qu'on on
s'charne contre les pauvres et on fait
on se fait le chantre du de la société
méritocratique comme si on était
responsable d'être pauvre comme si on
était responsable d'être chômage comme
si on était responsable d'avoir d'être
bénéficiaire d'un certain nombre de
d'êes sociales et euh donc il y aurait
les bons Français et les mauvais
français et qui aurait qu'à traverser la
rue pour aller trouver du travail mais
le monde de Gabriel Atal est un monde
qui n'est pas fait d'entorse qui n'est
pas fait de enfin qui qui est un monde
où il est bien né et il ne comprend pas
ce que vivent la vie des gens c'est
d'une perversité cette décision sur la
SS vous imaginez même pas enfin si vous
imaginez sans doute mais on va le savoir
d'autant plus qu'on va découvrir ce que
veut dire cette suppression de l'ASS
mais ça veut dire la location de
solidarité qui est supprimé qui touche à
la fin des droits au chômage donc ça
veut dire que dès qu'on aura plus ses
droits au chômage on va va passer
directement au RSA ça veut dire qu'on va
toucher alors certes une enveloppe un
peu plus importante mais qui pourra pas
être cumulable avec les aides au
logement qui ne comptera pas dans vot
trimestre pour la retraite avec cette
espèce d'accusation qui consiste à dire
mais vous rendez compte il y a des gens
qui touchent de l'argent et qui en
plus continuent à cotiser pour leur pour
leur retraite alors qu'il y a des gens
qui travaillent et qui bénéficient pas
de ces aides ça veut dire qu' met en
opposition et ça a toujours été sans
doute la stratégie de la droite la plus
réactionnaire c'estàdire d'opposer des
populations des populations qui sont
aidées légitimement par l'État parce
qu'ils ont un difficulté à retrouver le
chemin de l'emploi et puis les autres
les Français qui effectivement sont
souvent pas aidés parce que soit trop
aisés et et c'est cette manière de
d'opposer les populations qui est
insupportable et d'une perversité
notamment sur cette tête de laass je
trouve qui est assez déroutante quand
même voà sur laasss oui il y a un sujet
que Gabriel tal va devoir traiter c'est
que si on rentre dans la technique c'est
que le le
l'ASS euh est accessible plus facilement
que le RSA c'està que le plafond de
c'est c'est des allocations qui qui sont
versés sous conditions de ressources
donc à partir de d'un certain montant de
de de revenu dans un couple vous pouvez
plus toucher la location c'est un peu
logique mais mais les les les montants
en question sont plus favorables pour
laass que pour le RSA donc il y a
effectivement un risque que certaines
personnes se retrouvent dans dans une
situation en tout cas à l'échelle de
leur couple ou de leur foyer un peu plus
pauvre qu'avant donc évidemment là il y
a il y a un effet de seuil que que
Gabriel devir devra regarder après pour
le RSA faut rappeler quand même que en
théorie c'est une aide qui bénéficie
aussi d'un accompagnement et donc on
laisse pas les gens qui en sont
bénéficiaires bah totalement à l'abandon
normalement le RSA c'est quelque chose
qui vous permet d'avoir des aussi des
des des gens qui vont vous aider à
retrouver du travail à retrouver des
formations euh c'est pas forcément le
cas pour laass parce que à SS
normalement vous êtes toujours sous
contrôle entre guillemets de de de Pôle
emploi mais ça veut pas dire que il
s'occupe vraiment bien de vous en tout
cas il y a des cas concrets qui qui qui
le montrent ça c'est c'est le point sur
laass ensuite sur son thème à gabrielal
de désmicardiser la France c'est très
intéressant parce qu'on a eu depuis la
hausse d'inflation d' a 2 ans de plus en
plus de Français qui se retrouvent au
SMIC et qui ne bénéficient plus de de
hausse de salaire qui était accessible
au-dessus du SMIC donc là il y a
vraiment un sujet que le gouvernement
veut résoudre et CIT de débloquer le les
les progressions salariales dans les
entreprises évidemment c'est pas lui qui
décide des salaires mais il a à sa main
des outils qui sont les allaisements de
cotisation ou
ce qui le RSA activité anciennement
prime pour l'emploi bon mais Gabriel
Atal il donne cette perspective il
suggère que l'État va pouvoir débloquer
des choses mais il faut des moyens pour
ça et il ne les a pas parce qu'en même
temps il y a la promesse de réduire le
déficit public et les seuls moyens dont
il dispose c'est les fameux 2 milliards
d'euros qu'Emmanuel Macron a promis de
consacrer au classe moyenne est-ce que
ces 2 milliards d'euros iront sur
uniquement sur des personnes qui sont en
emploi à des salaires légèrement
supérieurs au SMIC c'est intéressant
mais il l'a pas dit hier donc ça reste
une promesse qui conceptuellement est
très séduisante mais en terme
d'application on demande encore à voir
ouais mais est-ce que vous parlez
d'opposer les France les unes aux autres
est-ce que il a pas eu raison de
s'adresser notamment à à ces classes
moyennes à cette France de l'entre deux
comme il a appelé hier cette France qui
gagne trop pour avoir des aides mais pas
assez pour vivre convenablement
qu'est-ce qu'il leur a proposé à cette
France là enfin il a proposé quoi en
terme d'augmentation c'estàd que quand
il parle de libéraliser de libérer les
énergies libérer
l'économie ulaire que l'on connaît bien
et dont on sait vers quoi il va
c'estàdire que destruction du droit du
travail il y est allé c'està-dire qu'il
veut aller encore plus loin sur là où là
où se joue la négociation c'està-dire
qu'il y a plus de il y a plus de
sécurité sociale de de de protection
sociale à l'échelle nationale il a dit
qu'il fallait que la négociation se
fasse entreprise par entreprise on a on
a l'air de dire qu'effectivement c'est
pas le gouvernement qui décide des
augmentations de salaires mais enfin
siil décid de convoquer le patronal les
syndicats autour d'une table qui se
mettent pendant 10 jours à négocier vous
pouvez ressortir de là en disant comme
ça s fait lors des Accords de Grenet
alors certes pas c'est pas c'est pas pas
révolutionnaire mais ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on abouti quand même à sur des
augmentations de Sala plus
jamais mais pourquoi il faudrait pas le
refaire un moment donné mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que le rôle des
organisations syndicales c'est aussi de
négocier avec le patronat ce que je veux
dire c'est que on a là aussi quand je
dis que c'est un pouvoir libéral
réactionnaire mais aussi c'est une
reprise en main politique de l'ensemble
de la chose publique où tout se décide à
l'échelle d'Emmanuel Macron et
possiblement un peu avec Emmanuel avec
Gabriel sans sans les syndicats sans le
patronat ce que jeux dire c'est qu'
moment doné ce qui concerne la vie des
Français ça se négocie la démocratie
sociale elle devrait encore un peu plus
exister dans ce pays qui est en crise et
puis quand quand il nous explique qu'il
faut désmicardiser ce pays qui est
responsable de l'augmentation de 12 à 17
% de la smicardisation en France
aujourd'hui c'est l'inflation ben certes
c'est l'inflation mais qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont fait pour qu'est-ce qui a été fait
qu'est-ce qui a été fait je veux dire il
y a un certain nombre de mouvements
politiques aujourd'hui alors certes
qu'ils sont pas majoritaires mais il y a
de droite comme de gauche certains
proposent aujourd'hui d'indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation il faut pas
qu'il a que le SM qui soit indexé sur
sur
l'inflation il y a quand même une
position très passive de ce gouvernement
sur les effet de cette stincardisation
donc qui nous explique aujourd'hui qu'il
veille dtincardiser en papérisant la
population française non ça ne passe pas
je trouve que ce discours est d'un est à
côté de la plaque c'est vraiment à côté
de la plaque il y a pas de proposition
concrète alors il y a des propositions
ce qui fait ce qui a été dit assz drôle
parce qu'on a dit presque un un un
secrétaire d'État qui est venu à la
tribune hier proposer bre de petites
propositions mais quand vous êtes dans
une galère pas possible au quotidien
vous dites mais il m'a proposé quoi moi
pour mon salaire et puis pour pour ma
précarité de l'emploi parce que c'est ça
qui se passe leur obsession à vouloir
faire le plein emploi ils précarisent
ils veulent la société d'Emmanuel Macron
on rêve d'être chef d'entreprise en
étant entrepreneur vous bénéficiez
d'aucune aide et vous faites croire aux
gens qui vont pouvoir vivre de leur
travail ce qui est absolument pas le cas
c'est un monde rêvé de de d'Emmanuel
Macron qui n'existe pas et qui ne fait
que précariser les
Français je parlerai pas de rêve mais
juste de réalité il y a quand même un
Tau chômage qui est au plus bas depuis
20 ans et qui est une réalité très
concrète c'est un fléo qui a ravagé la
société française et la politique depuis
les années 80 et il y a quand même
aujourd'hui des choses qui ont beaucoup
changé en
revanche c'est peut-être la difficulté
pour Gabriel natal c'est que le chômage
les experts vous expliquent qu' il
risque de remonter cette année parce que
le ralentissement économique fait qu'il
y aura moins de création d'emploi et ça
c'est un peu un non dit pour le
gouvernement c'est même carrément un un
dénis où on veut pas voir que cette
situation conjoncturelle elle va poser
problème ces prochains mois peut-être
même tout au long de l'année là il y a
pas de de de de de constat et il y a pas
non plus de de réponse de la part de
l'exécutif c'est un peu surprenant euh
et on peut s'attendre à ce que les
annonces hier de de Gabriel en tout cas
ces chantiers soient freinés par la
mauvaise conjoncture des prochains mois
et on va voir les réactions de
l'opposition à ce discours de Gabriel
hatal Marine Le Pen qui lui a répondu
hier dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale on également écouté Fabien
Roussel et Bruno retaillot qui eux lui
ont répondu ce matin les voix et moyens
du redressement je n'ai pas senti le
grand souffle qui puisse emporter le
pays vers des lendemains heureux et pour
tout dire je n'ai senti aucun
souffle dans ce catalogue de mesur
éparce et parfois contradictoire vous
tentez d'allier un peu de droite et un
peu de gauche et en réalité vous
accommoder le pire de la droite et le
pire de la gauche un discours qui
culpabilise les Français du chômage
c'est à cause des chômeurs s'il y a de
la pauvreté c'est à cause des
bénéficiaires du RSA et s'il y a des si
on narrive pas à trouver des médecins
c'est à cause des Français qui prennent
trop de rendez-vous et qui viennent pas
euh bref bah c'est pas un peu
caricatural ah bah c'est ce que j'ai
entendu excusez-moi ENF si ça va mal
c'est à cause de nous et c'est pas de sa
faute c'est comme la smicardisation de
la France il y a le nombre de smicard
est passé en France de 12 % 2017 quand
Emmanuel Macron est arrivé au pouvoir à
plus de 17 % aujourd'hui c'est quand
même pas de notre faute hein c'est quand
même un petit peu le résultat de leur
politique donc euh les Français ont bien
du mal à joindre les debouts à élever
leurs enfants à payer le facture mais
c'est toujours notre faute et ça ça
commence à bien faire je pense
qu'aujourd'hui euh il faut lui laisser
une chance il y a eu des mots on va voir
aux actes mais on verra surtout aux
résultats mais je pense que dans les
prochains mois nous devrons déposer une
motion de censure parce que on voit bien
que il est prisonnier du bilan il a
passé au moins 20 minutes sur son
discours à justifier le bilan d'Emmanuel
Macron qui est en train de nous amener
dans le mur donc il ne va pas pouvoir se
défaire de ce bilan et donc il y a pas
de princip du mais provisoirement il y a
pas de logiciel
[Musique]
nouveau on va commencer par Bruno
retaillot peêtre Nicolas qui était ce
matin sur TF1 alors il faut laisser une
chance à Gabriel Atal mais quand même
dans les prochains mois on sera obligé
de déposer une motion de censure et oui
il faut quand même laisser une chance à
Gabriel Atal parce que on l'a entendu
dans son discours hier et puis certaines
réaction aussi il a des postures qui
séduisent particulièrement à droite et
il a cette réminiscence de de de Nicolas
Sarkozi qui consiste à avec talent
d'ailleurs annoncer des mesures en les
replaçant dans un sens et en leur
donnant un contexte très concret et ça
c'était la marque de fabrique de de
l'ancien président de la République
d'arriver à raconter une une histoire
peut-être même une belle histoire avec
une mesure qui parfois était assez
limitée bon donc ça c'était c'est on va
dire sur le plan politique c'est c'est
intéressant de voir que les républicains
se sont fait un peu piquer les les
recettes de celui qui qui reste quelque
part un peu leur mentor même si beaucoup
le le renit euh ensuite évidemment Bruno
rotillo se rappelle que bah il est dans
l'opposition et que depuis le depuis
2017 les républicains sont dans une une
posture de de
faiblesse assez inédit dans dans dans
leur histoire que le fait que il dépose
un jour un jour il a pas donné de date
il a quelques mois une motion de censure
ça peut faire chuter le gouvernement
parce que les autres Mo autres
oppositions ont fait savoir en tout cas
c'était le cas sis B born que un jour
elles aussi et ben ell participeraiit
tout ensemble à une grande et belle
motion de censure pour pour faire du mal
à Emmanuel Macron bon on peut s'amuser
de de cette contradiction on peut aussi
douter fortement qu'il un jour une
motion de censour des républicains parce
que les républicains n'auraient pas de
majorité alternative et il serait bien
dans l'embarras de faire chuter un
gouvernement de nommé par Emmanuel
Macron pour mener quelle politique
aujourd'hui l'électorat de droite
constate que en tout cas pour beaucoup
que ces idées sont portées par le
gouvernement de Gabriel Attal avec de
des des propositions qu'on a entendu
hier donc on va dire que pour les
républicains l'équation reste intacte
ouais et on a entendu hier à nouveau
Gabriel àal redire he qu'il avait pas
qu'il avait qu'une majorité relative et
tendre la main aux oppositions d qu'il
serait toujours là pour débattre pour
discuter avec elle mais est-ce que quand
même il aura les moyens de mettre en
œuvre ce qu'il a proposé hier bah c'est
vrai que c'est c'est ça reste toute la
la tâche la plus compliquée pour pour
Gabriel àal mais c'est vrai que ce que
fait la droite est quand même assez
ahurissant quand même parce que bon
d'abord il y a à peu près autant de
droite qu'il existe de parlementaires
aujourd'hui on voit bien que la droite
parlementaire enfin la droite
sénatoriale et la droite à l'Assemblée
c'est pas tout à fait la même et et je
suis d'accord avec l'idée que quand même
ce que fait aujourd'hui Gabriel Atal
c'est le projet que la droite a toujours
rêvé de mettre en œuvre c'est pas pour
rien que d'ailleurs hashid hadti
explique aujourd'hui qu'il y a du
Nicolas Sarkozi dans Gabriel Atal les
politiques bon d'abord on sait tous que
Nicolas Sarkozi maintenant le nouveau
directeur des ressources humaines de
d'Emmanuel Macron mais on voit bien
qu'effectivement la politique qui est
menée cette politique très libérale où
on va casser le code du travail où on va
renforcer l'ordre de de ce enfin il y a
de la droite clairement dans dans dans
dans ce gouvernement donc la la droite
ne sait pas très bien sur quel pied
dansancer c'est vrai que je crois pas
non plus beaucoup à la menace qui est
lancée par la droite de déposer un jour
une motion de censure c'est vrai que si
la droite devait déposer une motion de
censure à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
de fortes chances qu'elle passe parce
que ça veut dire que l'extrême droite et
la gauche voterait à l'unisson une une
motion de censure quand même il serait
pas d'accord sur les termes utilisés
donc ça veut dire que le gouvernement de
Gabriel Atal tomberait est-ce que la
droite euh qui prend d'ailleurs des
tangences parfois un peu étonnantes hein
vous voyez quand elle a critiqué la
décision du conseil de constitutionnel
en se mettant en disant euh en en niant
le l'État de droit on peut se dire
qu'effectivement peut-être un jour elle
finira par faire affaiblir nos
institutions est-ce qu'elle en est
capable à tout de suite maintenant j'en
suis pas si sûr et puis par ailleurs ils
sont pas tous d'accord entre eux donc
c'est pas encore sûr que qu'il fasse
tomber ce gouvernement mais pierre vous
parlez du fond mais moi j'iniste un peu
plus sur la forme parce que c'est
important elle fait partie d'une d'une
stratégie qui est de faire reculer enfin
don l'objectif est de faire reculer le
rassemblement national et l'analyse
politique qui est faite c'est que en
ayant des postures de fermeté et en
parlant de choses très concrète le
gouvernement pourrait s'adresser et être
compris par cet électorat qui est
sensible à l'extrême droite en et en
réhabilitant en quelque sorte la
politique donc c'est c'est une stratégie
l'action politique c'est une stratégie
qui est qui est
menée frontalement par par Gabriel
effectivement c'est pas dit que ça
marche mais mais qui me paraît
intéressante à analyser aussi
aujourd'hui parce que elle avait été en
son temps on vient de l'évoquer mené par
par Nicolas sarzi avec un certain succès
puisque à son époque le le Jean-Marie Le
Pen au premier tour de en en en 2007
avait nettement reculé par rapport à
2002 donc il y a il y a cette idée que
en reprenant ses recettes et en montant
de la fermeté et des choses serès
concrète donc en fait en dépolitisant un
peu le débat en étant plus sur les idées
ni sur le fonctionnement du pays et bien
on on parviendrait à réenchanter
l'action politique et à séduire à
nouveau je trouve que ce Paris il est
très intéressant et et on aura les
résultats assez rapidement avec les
élections européennes est-ce qu'il est
suffisant pour donner un horizon une
perspective un cap évidemment non mais
il semble que ce soit pas du tout la
priorité pour Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui ouais et et d'où ce bras de
fer hier qui a eu qu'on a vu entre
Gabriel Attal et et Marine Le Pen un
dernier pierre il nous reste 30 secondes
gabrielal qui dans ses réponses après le
discours de politique générale
avertement tensé les députés RN et
Marine Le Pen oui c'est le problème moi
je pense en tout cas de ce gouvernement
c'est de considérer que c'est en allant
sur le terrain de l'extrême droite en
allant sur le terrain des propositions
de l'extrême droite qui vont réussir à
faire battre l'extrême droite non on
aura toujours enfin on sait très bien
qu'on préfère toujours l'original à la
copie et que c'est en menant des
politiques justement qui vont à
l'encontre des analyses et des
propositions d'extrême droite qu'on
combat l'extrême droite c'est pas du
tout le chemin qui est pris par ce
gouvernement allez on continue de parler
de gabrielal il est à la une de vos
quotidiens ce
[Musique]
matin et Gabriel hatal à la Une de
plusieurs de vos quotidiens régionaux le
style Atal à l'épreuve du feu titre le
républiain Laurent Atal tousasimute pour
mi libre le Premier ministre qui était
donc hier devant les députés pour
présenter son projet pour la France
c'est le titre de la Dépêche du Midi un
discours au cours duquel il a fait
plusieurs annonces sur le travail la
lutte contre le trafic de drogue ou la
santé àal promet du concret pour le télé
gr et maintenant c'est la question que
posent les journaux du centre de la
France dont la montagne avec cette photo
d'agriculteur et pour la Charente Libre
Gabriel Atal n'éteint pas la colère
agricole une colère qui s'étend et qui
gagne la Corse c'est à la Une de cors
matin avec des opérations
escargo et aux revendications nationales
s'ajoute là-bas des problématiques
insulaires une colère qui a des
conséquences dans les supermarchés comme
le montre l'ardenis avec cette photo de
rayon qui se vide c'est un drame qui
fait la une des journaux de Marseille
celui d'un incendie qui a eu lieu la
nuit dernière dans une cité du 15e
arrondissement de la ville le bilan est
lourd un enfant de 4 ans est mort
d'autres ont été intoxiqué un homme est
lourdement brûlé calisté sous le choc
pour la Provence nouveau drame du
logement pour la Marseillaise et puis on
termine avec cette question à la Une de
Presse Océan Bretagne à 5 quel impact
une étude sur le rattachement de la
Loire Atlantique à la région Bretagne a
été publiée hier les deux collectivités
demandent à l'État de s'engager sur un
référendum pierre regarde laopolitis les
agriculteurs évidè est dans le Pr
comment la colère est dans le prê non la
colère sort du Pr col on aurait pu faire
la colère dans le prê on a ce débat de
la rédaction un peu trop mais bon là
voilà du Pr donc on revient évidemment
sur la sur la fronde des des
agriculteurs et et avec des analyses
politique et et
évidemment voilà on revient sur les mots
on revient sur cette colère qui vient de
loin Nicolas à lire dans La Tribune
dimanche on sera nécessairement sur les
les suites du du discours de politique
général et maintenant que va-t-il se
passer les applications concrètes et on
lira ça avec attention dimanche merci
beaucoup Nicolas merci Pierre d'avoir
été avec nous merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi cet après-midi vous suivrez bien
sûr en direct sur notre antinne le
discours de Gabriel Atal devant les
sénateurs avec notamment des annonces
sur les territoire ce sera à suive à
partir de 15h et puis à l'analyse à 18h
dans sens public avec Thomas H très
bonne journée à
demain